exceptional highs
crushing lows
boris johnson with something special in
british politics a man whose story
gripped the country and could never be
ignored
boris johnson was never a child to be
carried along by life's tides instead he
would use it to propel him to his
destination
knowing he wanted to be world king aged
eight knowing he had a knack for being
lucky but trouble never far behind i'm
apologizing obviously for all the events
i've caused and for any hurt
that people feel
a graduate trainee on the times but
sacked the
misrepresentation brussels correspondent
to the telegraph but were the stories
always completely true
by the time he reached the editor's
chair of the spectator he was a big
enough figure to breeze through
challenges that would have stymied
lesser men and women combining magazine
editor with mp for henley in 2001. they
do art boris johnson has been elected
his political career stalled briefly
rather than stopped after being sacked
as a shadow junior minister for lying
about an affair
it was because of rather than in spite
of that rambunctious reputation that he
won the mayoralty in labour london i
therefore officially
declare boris johnson
to be elected as the next mayor of
london
the heineken politician for reaching
those outer london suburbs in numbers
that other tories couldn't boris johnson
the mayor of london
then he got a london birth but a
national platform in the form of the
2012 olympics
are we ready
yes we are
at his best boris johnson was a
politician who intuited moods crowds
fears and above all
hope
his career was all about proving
doubters wrong people are coming from
around the world
and they're seeing us
and they're seeing the greatest city on
earth
then he was a politician speaking for
the whole of the nation
but it wasn't until he picked aside that
he put himself on the path to become
prime minister i don't think there's
anything else i can do i will be
advocating uh vote leave that side was
the campaign to leave the european union
boris johnson got himself slogans jokes
and most of all a prop folks this is a
once in a lifetime unrepeatable
opportunity for us to take back control
it worked because he looked like he was
having fun on the campaign trail
sky news is projecting that the uk
has voted out
it was a stunning victory against an
establishment to remain which started
with every advantage
proving doubters wrong
theresa may made him foreign secretary
only for him to resign two years later
over her brexit plan
once more picking a sign to get ahead
at his most comfortable on the campaign
trail this time the goal was downing
street and the path a no-frills brexit
boris johnson is elected as the leader
of the conservative and unionist party
his arrival
looked like it had united a broken tory
party around a plan that then proved
hard to deliver
[Applause]
the first five months were as turbulent
as any scene by a modern prime minister
not a good start boris as he sought a
brexit deal and then tried to pass it
through the commons his breakthrough was
getting an election
and winning an 80 strong majority again
sent doubters packing this this morning
i i went to
buckingham palace
and i am forming a new government it
allowed boris johnson to finally deliver
brexit at the end of january 2020
but just as he got brexit done boris
johnson had a new foe more deadly than
any faced before on the other side of
the globe where coronavirus was starting
to spread
like everybody else his attention was
initially elsewhere his instincts to
shrug i was at a hospital the other
night where i think there were a few
there were actually a few coronavirus
patients and i shook hands with
everybody you'll be pleased to know
but it began to infect and take over the
body politic until it could not be
ignored
i must give the british people a very
simple instruction
you must stay at home
and then it began to take over him
first of all in my own case uh although
i'm feeling better and i've done my my
seven days of isolation alas i still
have one of the symptoms
but after a stay in intensive care he
was back to face a yet bigger challenge
steering the country through a global
pandemic which despite lockdowns and
restrictions just wouldn't let go almost
a year into coronavirus and he was still
cancelling christmas with six days to go
one man had been at boris johnson's side
throughout the leave campaign the
election and the pandemic dominic
cummings a controversial figure he
picked fights with every part of what he
saw as the westminster establishment
and eventually his boss was the target
walking out of number 10 and becoming
one of johnson's most vociferous critics
through every difficult moment boris
johnson and his supporters would
highlight two big achievements
first there was the brexit deal he'd
tell you he got brexit done
formally leaving the eu then almost a
year later cutting economic ties much of
the trickiest work on trade in northern
ireland still left to do however a true
verdict on its success and failings can
only be made in the decades to come
second was the vaccination program first
in the world to authorize it first in
the world to roll it out at speed for
many months far faster than the eu there
were moments of personal celebration too
a westminster wedding to his partner
carrie honeymoon plans delayed the
problems were piling up
his health secretary matt hancock out
after it emerged he was in a
relationship with a taxpayer-funded
colleague
then brexit supporter and political bed
fellow owen patterson guilty of lobbying
while accepting cash initially defended
by boris johnson then abandoned and also
out
then there were the problems piling up
queues at petrol stations shortages of
lorry drivers migrants crossing the
channel prices everywhere rising the
strange showing in front of business
leaders
forgive me
forgive me i don't know if you've been
to peppa pig world who's been depends
i've anybody's been to pep a big world
not enough
and finally it was the personal
peccadillos that really did for him and
the word no politician wants to be
associated with sleaze
who paid for the holidays in mystique or
the donor-funded refurbishment of his
flat above number 11.
then the christmas parties in downing
street during lockdown made the public
wonder if this footage of his press
secretary allegra stratton joking about
parties was the johnson administration
laughing at them from the corridors of
power
and it was not socially distanced
but as the allegations grew and grew mr
johnson became trapped in a web of
rule-breaking and half-truths and
untruths of his own making nobody told
me i can absolutely i'm absolutely
categorical as nobody said to me
this is an event that is against the
rules
that is in breach of
what we're asking everybody else to do
should not go ahead what i remember is
going out into that garden for a short
time but the metropolitan police
disagreed and soon partygate became a
byword for bad behavior hypocrisy and a
seeming contempt for the rules senior
civil servant sue gray investigated but
left the final judgment up to the
conservative party and the public
boris johnson became the first prime
minister to be found to have broken the
law in office and fined he tried to
mount a damaged limitation exercise to
contain the uproar from the public and
his mps
but it wasn't enough to prevent a
challenge to his
leadership and a vote against was 148
votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
victory but still damaging and painful
148 of his own mps voting no confidence
in their leader not enough to oust boris
johnson from number 10 but a sign his
party were turning on him
the voters too double defeat in
by-elections in tibetan and wakefield
two very different seats sending the
same message
it's time to show boris the door
[Applause]
[Music]
the party chair oliver dowden resigned
saying someone must take responsibility
the prime minister still didn't think
that should be him
the final straw however was the
resignation of a man few outside
westminster had heard of from a job most
wouldn't have known existed chris
pincher appointed in february as deputy
chief whip stood down five months later
after allegations of sexual harassment
but pincher had form for this sort of
behavior and officials had repeatedly
warned the pm of such
first boris johnson tried denying he
knew specific details
[Music]
after five days the story changed and he
conceded he'd simply forgotten what he'd
been told
again questions about whether boris
johnson was deliberately withholding the
truth
[Applause]
patterson parties and now pinscher trust
amongst his mps was finally gone
first his chancellor and health
secretary resigned and then a tsunami of
colleagues quit in their wake
the boy who once said he wanted to be
king dethroned a winner
cast out without the party knowing what
comes next
sam coates sky news westminster